battles in persona 5 are way more than
opposing characters exchanging blows
it's a deep combat system where your
inner self is personified as a pseudo
sidekick who cast spells and if you
manage to discover and exploit an
enemy's weakness you're rewarded with an
extra turn where your current character
can pile onto punishment or pass the
beatdown baton to a buddy this video
showcases a hearty sampling of persona
fives combat and a stylish mayhem that
can unfold in a given encounter if you
enjoyed this persona 5 video give us a
thumbs up and subscribe to our channel
while you're there check out our history
of persona video which can make you a
persona trivia expert in less than 30
minutes and if you'd like to see other
areas of persona 5 let us know in the
discussion below thanks for watching
[Music]
[Music]
well on to the next triumph
[Music]
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pretty hard to drive on the rails
not really made for cars after all you
can do it Mona
[Music]
just walk around somewhere bizarre
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well on to the next triumph
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
all right
I can feel it
[Music]
this rights wouldn't be asleep
yeah I get that on trains - yeah but
don't fall asleep here or else we're
screwed oh yeah yeah
[Music]
listen
[Music]
what was that
[Music]
I am now
[Music]
hold on
[Music]
[Music]
time for this
[Music]
all right thanks much thanks
[Music]
[Music]
this is my other self
[Music]
[Music]
using
[Music]
ravished up
[Music]
it's step one what is